I'm your Ghost of Christmas presents
Like A Christmas Carol
[Music]
on a bitter cold Christmas Eve one Dark
Soul is selected for Redemption by the
ghosts of Christmas past present and yet
to come a tradition that continues to
this very Night
Like A Christmas Carol yes yes if you
would just let me get this out sit so
out of all the people on the planet
murderers people who do gender reveal
parties I'm the guy you're gonna hunt
you know what forget it
I told you the guy is a level 20 band in
the Dickens come on I can take this guy
I'm your Ghost of Christmas present
I'm not watching your dramatic
re-encrapment hey I'm haunting you you
can't just run away from me when I'm
haunting you hello
I believe he can be a positive force for
mankind and he's got his hands all over
everything yeah I wish mod are you
texting HR no
people don't change we got a runner
that's just fun to watch
I'm here to change into being a more
positive force for Humanity
[Laughter]
Photoshop yourself into these pictures
of my executive VP thanks so
[Music]
that what I want is for you to shut up
and let me do my job is there a Ghost of
Christmas grumpy because you could do
that job
foreign